mais tout de suite notre premier devant
avec une question mais où est passé le
et en même temps vous souvenez le
maquereau niçois au début incarner une
forme de troisième voie il n'était ni de
gauche ni de droite aujourd'hui pour
paraphraser ce que françois mitterrand
disait jadis du centre il paraît surtout
ni de gauche ni de gauche on a vu hier
un président de la république exploiter
des thèmes traditionnels du champ de la
droite alors explications et réactions
avec hugo lemonnier un président en
campagne avant l'heure tout au long de
son allocution emmanuel macron a livré
un discours de candidat de droite avec
un mot répété à une vingtaine de
reprises au cours de son intervention le
travail le travail continue donc d'être
notre boussole le fil rouge de notre
action la réforme des retraites sera
repoussé un éventuel second quinquennat
mais le président insiste il faudra
repousser l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite
travailler plus longtemps en repoussant
l'âge légal aller vers un système plus
juste en supprimant les régimes spéciaux
en harmonisant les règles entre public
et privé et en faisant en sorte qu'au
terme d'une carrière complète aucune
pension ne puisse être inférieure à 1000
euros nouveau thème de campagne et
autres marqueurs de la droite le
nucléaire pour garantir l'indépendance
énergétique de la france pour garantir
l'approvisionnement électrique de notre
pays et atteindre nos objectifs en
particulier la neutralité carbone en
2050 nous allons pour la première fois
depuis des décennies
relancer la construction de réacteurs
nucléaires dans notre pays autant
d'appels du pied aux électeurs les
républicains qui gêne les prétendants à
la candidature de la droite en novembre
2018 s'était pas voilà un siècle il
annonce la fermeture de 14 réacteurs il
laisse fermer fessenheim et c'est le
même qui vient nous dire aujourd'hui à
écouter on va relancer le nucléaire non
peut pas lui faire confiance on voit un
président sous la pression de la droite
qui veut faire et à il veut faire
oublier quoi il veut faire oublier
l'échec de son quinquennat un
quinquennat pour presque rien si le
président n'est pas encore
officiellement entrée en campagne
emmanuel macron a dessiné sa stratégie
siphonner un peu plus l'électorat de
droite
emmanuel macron est il en train de
siphonner la droite alors on en parle ce
soir avec mes invités olivier paccaud
vous êtes sénateur apparenté à l'air de
l'oise est par ailleurs porte-parole de
xavier bertrand dans cette campagne du
congrès à vos côtés sacha ollier bonsoir
vous êtes député lrm de la vienne ancien
socialiste peut-être une des voitures
des génériques macron une des voix de
l'une des voix de gauche de la majorité
on peut dire ça vous pouvez dire ça oui
très bien j'accueille également albert
et nous rédacteur en chef des pages
politique du figaro bonsoir et puis bien
sûr l'éthicien krupa nos transports
nicaise qui m'accompagnera tout au long
de l'émission et puis par écran
interposé
pierre-adrien bartoli directeur des
études politiques chez harris
interactive qui interviendra lui aussi
tout au long de cette émission pour
commencer ce débat j'ai envie de faire
un petit tour de table et vous poser une
question simple aujourd'hui pour vous
emmanuel macron il est de gauche de
droite ou ailleurs albert et nos îles et
il est à la fois de droite est à la fois
de gauche antonio casilli les seuils de
toujours de toujours jouer cette
carte-là avec
c'est une petite priorité à donner à la
droite on a vu que en 2017 il avait été
élu plus tôt avec des voix de gauche
avec des élus dans sa chaire liée plutôt
de gauche on le voit d'ailleurs il ya un
problème au sein du ca même du groupe à
1 kg est plutôt à gauche on y est
mais au cours très rapidement au cours
de son mandat et à une translation
l'électorat c'est plutôt est plutôt
reportée sur la droite on l'a vu aux
élections des élections européennes on
voit bien que le réceptacle plutôt à
droite ça répond pas à la question lui
jaune pour o il est de gauche d'europe
moi je pense qu'il est il est
fondamentalement de gauche et c'est avec
un certain qui vient de la gauche
qu'elle son adn est plutôt social
démocrate et et part peut-être par
opportunisme politique aussi il sait il
s'est trouvé s'est trouvée sur avec des
accointances avec un électorat plutôt à
droite olivier paccaud il est de gauche
ou de droite emmanuel macron le
maquereau nist déjà et en fait moi je
pense que il est plutôt il va plutôt là
où il pense que le sens du vent va donc
il est de gauche quand il pense que la
gauche a peut-être quelque chose à lui
apporter électoralement et puis quand
celles à anvers il va être plutôt de
droite donc en ce moment effectivement
les thématiques qui l'a mise en avant
c'est vrai que hier pendant trois
minutes on a entendu 15 fois le mot
travail alors là c'est vrai que j'avoue
devant demande écran j'étais un petit
peu stupéfait je croyais en tant que
xavier bertrand donc là aujourd'hui il
est peut-être un petit peu de droite
hier il était de gauche et puis ici il
sent que le climat social change et
politiques changent un peu mais changera
opportuniste un caméléon edgar fort
hills
j'espère qu'elle sera pas morte pour les
saoudiens il est de gauche ou de droite
le président macro ni c'est une bonne
définition en fait on a réfuté le fait
que le travail c'est appartiennent à un
camp ou un autre on a même fait notre
élément central de campagne en 2017 en
disant qu'on allait retrouver à tout le
moins de travail qu'on allait faire que
ce travail paye il le fait est que
malgré la crise le taux de chômage s'est
effondré puisqu'on a énormément
travaillé pour cela que le travail et
mieux rémunéré et que les résultats sont
présents et que salar elle fait on fait
le bilan mais je vous parle de l'homme
c'est l'homme il est de droite ou les où
les biens sont tellement la construction
d'un marché de réfuter cette
construction 7 sur sa position
idéologique bougez pas vous dire qu'il
est de gauche ou de droite à partir du
moment où il ya des propositions qui
font écho effectivement à ce qu'est la
gauche et notamment tous les systèmes
d'aidés sociales l'interventionnisme
économique été mis en place pendant la
crise voire même la construction
européenne où nous allions à parler
lever des taxes au niveau européen pour
les gaffes ou pourrait justement carbone
et puis ya des éléments qui parle à la
droite le contrôle des chômeurs qui par
ailleurs est une mesure qui est déjà en
vigueur nous on y reviendra ou là où la
question part hier de de l'âge légal kit
inclut aussi la réforme des retraites
que nous avions proposé mais que lui
n'avait pas proposé pendant sa campagne
en 2017 si je ne m'abuse c'est
exactement exactement est ce qui
permettra par un événement démocratique
du mali d un nouvel élément puisque
c'est la réforme des retraites que nous
avons fait auquel on ajoute un élément
qui est l'âge légal donc voyant cela il
ya des éléments qui étaient la campagne
2010 est récupéré une valeur qui nous
est cher la valeur travail et puis
prendre des idées qui sont celles de la
gauche prendre des idées qui sont celles
là pour faire vivre notre vie donc le
fameux et en même temps et le fameux
mendy or si je vous écoute pierre-adrien
bartoli vous en tant que sont dehors
vous le classer ou
assez compliqué donc pour nous il est
effectivement macro nice t on a vu cette
nouvelle catégorie émergé en gros si on
refait l'histoire du quinquennat on a eu
beaucoup d'évolution on a eu au moment
de l'élection un président de la
république élu par grosso modo deux
tiers des lecteurs venus de la gauche
dans sa famille politique initiale et un
tiers venu de la droite les électeurs de
droite étant un peu plus conservateur
ayant vu de manière un peu plus distante
cette percée en 2017 mais très vite en
fait dès l'été 2010 est toute une part
des lecteurs allaient ils ont juppéiste
de la droite se sont rendus compte qu
emmanuel macron était pas forcément très
éloignées sur un certain nombre de
thèmes de ce que pouvaient porter et
attendre et l'ont rejoint --en lors des
élections européennes de 2019 la bascule
est fait d'ailleurs ça se voit très bien
sur les cartes électorales on a une
liste la république en marge qui grosso
modo obtient ses voix deux tiers à
droite cette fois ci et un tiers à
gauche toute la question va être une
nouvelle élection présidentielle avec
une participation potentiellement plus
élevés que les élections intermédiaires
qu'elle bascule il va ya voir d'où vont
venir les électeurs pour l'instant des
deux camps mais pas de manière uniforme
adrien bartoli qui parlent de cette
bascule en gros de l'électorat entre
l'électorat de gauche électorat de
droite albertaine ou est ce qu'il ya une
bascule de la politique gouvernementale
de la gauche vers la droite ou est-ce
que dès le début
elle était marquée à droite on peut
rappeler qu'elle était fait beaucoup
parler en dehors atteint un premier
ministre venu de l'ère edouard philippe
un second premier ministre jean castex
venue de l'air lui aussi des principaux
ministres venus de nerfs vous d'été de
caen cette bascule pas pas d'hier soir
je mène on va dire ça non elle était
déjà était déjà sensible assez assez
rapidement donc mais au début il y avait
il y avait la volonté d'avoir des
lavoirs d'avoir de marcher sur deux
pieds à la fois la gauche à droite
effectivement beaucoup de quelques
ministres qui compte revenait de la
vente mais y avait nicolas hulot qui par
habitation adeptes de droite il est
comme ça des ministres importants qui
sont nuls had de la gauche jean yves le
drian qui est qui est resté du soft qui
est passé rapidement de la gauche et à
droite je n'aime pas voter le budget le
premier budget donc et il y avait la
volonté d sur deux sur les sur les sur
les deux pieds et mes deux jambes perdus
au gendre comme du maquereau 10 mai
véro assez rapidement s'est aperçu que
il y avait une propension naturelle du
gouvernement et de démêler macron
d'aller plutôt ces sujets qui là où il
n'était pas très fort les sujets
régaliens je suis de sécurité sud
défense à rester présentes et prendre
dans un premier temps rappelé comme
comme à jupiter et voilà lettres droit
dans ses bottes il fallait pas les
respecter
ce qui faisait plaisir
symboliquement à l'électorat de droite
et est rapidement n'a plus on pas plus
de jupiter maintenant que c est ce que
je peux émettre une hypothèse qu'on m'a
pas posé ma classe
alors je dirais qu'en fait il est c'est
un président de droite
vraiment ils souhaitent et gouverner à
droite et la pandémie la force et a
finalement faire une politique de gauche
parce que l'état qui a protégé tous les
français avec le consentement de la
population évidemment puisque la
campagne de vaccination est un succès
cet état protecteur à mon avis est quand
même un ancrage très importants et un
signal très fort pour le peuple de
gauche l'état à protéger l'état a sauvé
des petites entreprises l'état a sauvé
des auto entrepreneurs des personnes qui
auraient pu basculer dans la précarité
de façon vraiment dramatique et c'est
emmanuel macron qui pour l'instant à la
paternité de ce sauvetage or il me
semble que quand même c'est ce que les
français ont aujourd'hui comme constat
immédiat et c'est un constat qui est de
gauche avec pour vous l'intervention
publique est un marqueur de gauche à
oublier en fait pas seulement parce que
si vous voulez il ya tout ce qui rend
beau régalien qui étaient déjà contenues
dans notre programme c'est à dire la
question de réinvestir dans les services
publics notamment de la police ou de la
justice qui étaient amplifiés notamment
par la nomination du garde des sceaux
eric dupond moretti et les bijoux budget
de la justice qui sont colossaux et qui
aujourd'hui atteint 30% soit en totalité
du quinquennat et puis l'autre côté la
création de nouveaux droits florent
dirigeants du budget guy lecomte à sous
du budget parle et sur cette question le
seul augmentation de nouveaux droits
cédés droit qui répond normalement une
idée qui vient plutôt de la gauche la
création d'une cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale dit au risque de la
dépendance la question de la du paiement
des pensions alimentaires impayées pour
toutes les femmes qui n'en a qui n'en
bénéficient pas ou les questions qui
sont celles de la reconstruction au
service qu'on dise entendez il est en
france un service avec l'investissement
dans les hôpitaux quand vous entendez
hier le de thème de la chasse aux faux
chômeurs qui était quand même un thème
traditionnel sarkozyste
dès 2008 quand vous entendez hier le
recul de l'âge légal qui était une
demande et qui est une demande d
candidat des républicains vous êtes à
l'aise avec ça vous saviez mais c'est
d'abord sur la question des chômeurs on
est d'abord c'est la question du travail
et donc effectivement c'est pas la
proposition que valoriserait le plus la
question de celles de la chasse aux
chômeurs comme vous l'appelez moi ce qui
m'a chômeurs en soi disant il faut chaud
mais ils sentent cette question si les
plus prisées par ce seul prisme elle
serait insuffisante est très
stigmatisante sauf que c'est la seule
zone est retenu hier dans ce que savent
que ce que l'on sait et nous aussi c'est
le premier ministre a annoncé au mois de
septembre il l'a fait à châtellerault un
plan de 4000 yards pour la formation des
personnes qui sont au chômage de longue
durée et donc vous voyez que dans cette
idée là il ya ce que nous proposons est
ce que nous construisons et ce qui
finalement est deux faces d'une même
pièce et l'ajout de l'information en
tentant de ce que disait cela cet
après-midi un ancien de vos camarades
d'un socialiste patrick kanner pour les
côtes
monsieur macron est en train de tam et
emma l'expression sucer la droite là si
c'est là la roue de la droite
avec une forme de déterminisme
incroyable incroyable et moi je
considère que là on va trop loin
finalement depuis hier soir on sait
qu'il y a non pas cinq candidats à la
primaire ait l'air mais si ça avec
monsieur macro on rappelle que c'est une
métaphore cycliste
aurait consommé
de l'inspiration juste avant de vous
donner par le dis pas qu ils nasa n'a
pas ému que patrick kanner cette
intervention du président ça débute pas
mal sur les bancs de la gauche cet après
midi lors des questions au gouvernement
vous y étiez quand un calme et on vous
accueille vous allez nous raconter
comment si vous avez swarm assister à
tous à la gauche est montée au créneau
cet après midi c'est ça on a vu des
questions de pas moins de trois groupes
de gauche les écologistes le pcf
également les socialistes alors on va
commencer avec ces communistes qui pour
eux ont bien vu hier une entrée en
campagne d' emmanuel macron écouter
cécile kerman
comment nous avons écouté un président
devenu candidat hier soir il n'a
pratiquement pas aborder la première
préoccupation des français le pouvoir
d'achat mais al'inverse
stigmatisation détestable des chômeurs
une vieille formule ressorti travailler
plus et plus longtemps mais silence
total sera osé salaires la hausse des
pensions la hausse des retraites jean
castex qui a pu répondre un peu plus
tard mais d'abord on va écouter les
écologistes avec guillaume vont par leur
chef de file pour le discours d'hier
c'était pas une vision du monde de
demain mais plutôt d'hier voire même
d'avant-hier et côté gontard la
croissance le productivisme le nucléaire
tous ces étendards des trente glorieuses
sonne si faux dans la bouche d'un homme
qui n'a pourtant connu que la crise
structurelle d'un capitalisme
incompatible avec la préservation du
vivant et la justice sociale un
autosatisfecit sidérant sur
l'investissement faveur de la santé
quand l'hôpital a perdu 5700 lit au
milieu de la pandémie comme sur la
pauvreté alors que la misère
s'intensifie toujours jean castex à vous
faire monsieur le député met donc jean
castex qu'a pu répondre à toutes ces
critiques notamment sur le fait que
c'est bien le prénom n'a plus qu'à les
stigmatiser les chômeurs avec cette
référence cette réforme de
l'assurance-chômage écouter jean castex
l'un des sujets du moment les questions
de pouvoir d'achat et d'inflation ont
été abordés effectivement vous le savez
toutes et tous vous le voyez dans vos
départements sait les difficultés à
recruter et non nous ne stigmatisons
personnes on ne peut pas nous avons a
reproché d'avoir suspendu la réforme
d'assurance chômage alors même que le
chômage monte et de veiller à son entrée
en vigueur ce sera pour tous ces
paramètres le 1er décembre prochain
alors que pour ces personnes
nous avons des emplois proposés voilà
une séance tendue et angoissant qui veut
travailler comme cela jusqu'au dernier
moment et donc ça promet d'autres
sections d'actu encore tendu jusque
février d'autres chroniques je
reviendrais et si beaucoup on va
s'intéresser aux conséquences pour la
droite est-ce que olivier paccaud vous
n'avez pas eu l'impression de vous faire
manger la laine sur le dos hier soir non
mais j'avoue que j'ai regardé avec une
certaine ironie effectivement le sixième
candidat de là la primaire de la droite
d'une certaine façon mais je veux quand
même d'abord dire une chose qui m'a
quand même profondément choqué et je
crois que c'est unanime hormis du côté
de la république en marche c'est le fait
qu'on a un président qui est candidat
qui ne le dit pas mais à partir du
moment où il est candidat il doit être
soumis aux règles
médiatique que le csa a fait respecter à
certains qui ne sont pas encore candidat
qu est-ce que c'est pas un peu le cas de
tous les présidents sortants c'est
peut-être un peu le cas tous les
présidents sortants mais là on a franchi
un cran supplémentaire avec une présence
sur toutes les chaînes quasiment de
télévision pendant une demi heure pour
faire pendant sept minutes donc un peu
de sanitaires pendant cinq minutes une
autosatisfaction assez impressionnante
et puis ensuite pendant 15 minutes une
déclaration de campagne avec une
conclusion je me croyais dans un meeting
alors je n'étais pas prêt à applaudir
mais il faut vraiment que le csa ne soit
pas le comité servile d'autosatisfaction
du gouvernement et j ça ça n'a jamais
servi au président sortant puisque
regarder n'ont jamais été réélu vous
devriez être content vous dire ah bah
finalement
c'est pour ça que je suis pas si inquiet
que ça et si à mon avis monsieur macron
effectivement je ne reprendrai pas
l'expression cycliste de l'amica nerfs
mais si effectivement il le reprend de
façon très étonnante les thèmes que
plusieurs candidats aient l'air ont mis
en évidence c'est parce qu'il se sent en
danger vis-à-vis de ses candidat j'en
suis intimement convaincu parce que si
xavier bertrand et une au congrès il
vient à présent la république alors on
va y venir c'est cette prédiction c'est
emmanuel macron le sait et en profite un
peu plus
prend des tons on va en parler juste une
chose d'abord vous n'êtes pas tout seul
à penser ça écouter ce que disait le
sénateur retailleau cet après midi
c'était le discours de la campagne
électorale et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense qu'il a pris les
français pour des imbéciles puisque il a
dit ce qu'il allait faire dans les cinq
prochaines années mais c'est autant de
points de réforme qui n'a pas fait
durant les cinq dernières années dont
justement la réforme de la retraite
c'est est patent et je pense que
beaucoup de français de l'en but vous
savez il ya des gens qui parle pour ne
rien dire mmmm macro lui parle pour ne
rien faire
sacha au lit je vous donne un chiffre
41% c'est le nombre de français qui ont
été convaincues par le président hier
soir selon un sondage aux hawks apparus
cet après midi qu'est ce que vous lui
réponds d'aller les paccots qu'un
président qui préside que ça choque les
oppositions je les comprends parce que
ça fait longtemps qu'elles n'ont pas vu
ça y compris dans leurs rangs et donc
qui voit un président de la république
sociale et sanitaire qui voit un prix
dans la république capable de nous
parler du bilan qui l'a conduit pendant
50 qui ont un prénom a rappelé capable
de dresser des perspectives pour notre
pays france 2030 notamment sur des fonds
d'investissement eh bien ça peut les
marchés parce que je crois qu'ils n'ont
pas ça dans le rang mais y'a pas un peu
une entourloupe de convoquer tous les
français à 20 heures pour parler de
salies terre et en fait leur déroule un
programme nos contradicteurs enfin ses
abords d'abord il ya eu une introduction
assez longue qui représente un tiers de
l'intervention sur le sur les sanitaires
est ce que j'ai dit un drm le tiers qui
était pas sanitaires et pour le coup il
n'y a pas de journalistes pour les
premiers qui sauva sauf à considérer que
l'action économique qui avait consisté à
endiguer la pauvreté en tout cas à ne
pas avoir quatre cent mille nouveaux
pauvres dans notre pays n'était pas lié
à la pandémie sauf à considérer que les
aides sectorielles ou les aides aux
entreprises s'étaient pas liée à la
pandémie sera considéré que les actions
contre le chômage alors qu'on nous
promettait une explosion du chômage
s'était pas liée à la pandémie de tout
ça tout ça c'est évidemment lié à
l'internet il sait que le plan de
relance la raison pour laquelle on avait
été convoqué le plan de relance une
soirée déguisée vous êtes le seul
déguisez vous allez trouver ça bizarre
d'abord moi je suis sûr à visage
découvert donc ça pose pas de problème
est ce que ce que je vais vous dire sur
ces sujets c'est qu'on a dit qu'on va
fermer jusqu'au bout donc on va réformer
jusqu'au bout et lorsqu'on veut faire
jusqu'au bout ça c'est aussi assorti des
annonces d'annoncés sont liés au fait de
ce que nous allons faire nous présentons
france est mort c'est qu'il est
président on sait qu'il est candidat
même s'il n'est pas encore déclaré
albert hainaut quelles conséquences pour
l air à votre avis est-ce que ça va les
pousser à l'est encore plus à droite pas
forcément je reviendrai bien sûr juste
le son d'un jeu doxa vous étiez doxa le
figaro
[Musique]
il y a il y avait un autre chiffre qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on suive un peu
la discussion 64% des personnes
interrogées pensent que c'est un
discours de campagne que les français ne
sont pas dupes ils ont bien vu et sont
bien vus lamaneurs ils ont bien vu que
le président qui s'expriment pendant 27
minutes 30 la télévision devant presque
20 millions de personnes dans toutes les
chaînes et vous pas une grande partie
des radios on voit bien que c'est pas
pour ça pour annoncer la troisième dose
est obligatoire puissant le 5 janvier à
ma question est ce que fait que mm macro
on parle et prennent des thèmes de
droite va pousser les républicains à
aller plus à droite encore c'est c'est
une possibilité mais je pense que les la
droite n'aurait pas intérêt à aller plus
à droite que ken lay il faut rester
danser danser ma danse on danse on dans
son couloir et à vouloir à vouloir
coller à la ou à l'autre on y paie on y
perd son identité esma bienne mais la
tentation elle et elle et elle peut être
elle peut être forte d'aller d'aller
chercher les voix là où elles sont on
sait bien qu'aujourd'hui l'électorat de
droite est plus à droite que qu'ils ne
l'étaient ya quelques années est ce qu
est ce que ça ne pourrait pas être l'
inverse laetitia après tout est-ce que
emmanuel macron occuperait un espace qui
est laissé libre par la droite qui
pourrait être tenté de courir après
c'est une hypothèse aussi que j'aime et
ce soir il me semble qu'ils plantent un
drapeau sur un territoire de la droite
qui est encore vierge c'est à dire le
territoire qui refusent le concept et le
mot de grand remplacement parce que je
ne sais pas si vous avez vu l sur lci je
parle sous contrôle xavier bertrand
valérie pécresse michel barnier eric
ciotti lui accepte complètement le terme
il était né aux entournures avec ce
concept qui est issu bien sûr de
l'antisémitisme et ensuite qui sait 30
on le connaît aucun des candidats n'a
vraiment rejeté de façon ferme c'est à
dire former fond ce cette thématique
porté par eric zemmour et c'est quand
même compliqué il me semble pour un
électeur de droite de devoir endosser ce
concept valérie pécresse par exemple a
dit je déteste ce mot mais poussez vous
savez c'était comme xavier bertrand non
mais c'est à dire non avec l'expression
mais ce qu'elle recouvre je sais
effectivement c'est un jeu de kevin mc
on veut jouer effectivement conscience
poussant la droite et une partie de la
droite vers l'extrême droite ils m'ont
dit en riant drian voulant faire faire
le faire dire aux candidats de droite
ont refusé leur emplacement refusé le
terme sinon vous êtes vous n'êtes plus
dans le champ était de victoire c'est
pas emmanuel macron qui était face à ses
jours
david
emmanuel macron et la république en
marge ou beaucoup de ça en tout cas
la situation d'avoir un double un duel à
au deuxième tour emmanuel battront
contre contre marine le pen aujourd'hui
le deuxième tour est moins évident et
mais il ya toujours cette tentation
d'avoir de bloquer la droite de l'allée
sait si vous êtes anti républicain si
vous êtes pour le remplacement vous
allécher regza moore sinon venez chez
moi non c'est un peu ce que l'ailé je
suis pas du tout d'accord les candidats
à l'investiture et l'air sont tout à
fait libres de se positionner par
rapport à cette thématique du grand
remplacement ils n'ont pas fait écouter
juste et après on en discute après ce
que disait le président justement dans
son éducation à ce sujet
croyons en la france en une france qui
reste elle même forte de son histoire de
sa culture de sa langue de sa laïcité de
ce qui l'unît forte de son esprit de
résistance à la dilution dans un monde
qui va à la soumission aux dogmes aux
obscurantismes
au retour du nationalisme
voilà c'est la té m mais après je ne dis
pas que ça va être efficace et que ces
gagnants je dis juste que c'est un
positionnement qui à droite et inédit
juste pour reprendre valérie pécresse
bourget aux cimes sa vie et bertrand
bayle pécresse par exemple a dit je
déteste cette expression parce qu'elle
elle donne le sentiment que tout est
foutu enfin on déteste pas cette
expression pour ça vous voyez donc
emmanuel macron a le champ libre il me
semble à droite pour les futurs
électeurs qui n'aurait pas envie de
voter pour un candidat qui porte cette
thématique du grand remplacement mais
qui serait tout de même à droite alors
on parlait juste quand même donné la
parole aussi à pierre adrien bartoli et
puis je vais vouloir passer bien sûr
après sur le plateau on parlait avec
albert et nous de cette tentative de
blocage de la droite est ce que la
droite elle est bloquée dans les
sondages bien adrien bartoli dans votre
dernières enquêtes d'intentions de vote
n est pas forcément bloqué parce que
dans les enquêtes que nous on réalise on
a une droite qui est entre 14 et 10 %
cette semaine ils ont 15 et 10 si on
élargit aux dernières au dr semaine en
revanche le problème c'est qu'on a des
électeurs qui sont tiraillés d'une part
par un vote qui pourrait être un vote
pour emmanuel macron grosso modo on a
aujourd'hui un tiers des électeurs qui
pourraient choisir xavier bertrand qui
nous disent on alternative je ne suis
pas encore sûr de mon vote évidemment la
compagnie n'ont pas eu lieu je pourrais
être tentés par un vote emmanuel macron
donc à ce tir là qui pourrait se décrire
décroché vers le centre et puis on a eu
notre part des lecteurs plutôt sur la
droite des républicains cette fois ci
qui nous disent au fond pas tellement ce
que dit marine le pen mais surtout ce
que dit eric zemmour ça nous parle ça
nous intéresse on parlait du grand
remplacement n'oublions pas que parmi
les gens qui aujourd'hui se sent proche
de dlr on a 80 % un peu plus d'ailleurs
que 80% de ces français là qu'ils ont
peur de ce concept de cette idée qui a
derrière de grands emplacements et qui
se disent enfin un candidat qui en parle
qui parle d'un problème que moi je vois
où je ressens donc pourquoi pas voté
pour lui et donc on n'a pas un problème
d espace pour les tic pour la droite on
a plutôt un problème d'offre qui est
importante qui est différente et
l'intérêt pour les différents candidats
à ce stade c'est de marquer
effectivement leur territoire leur
différence pour pouvoir capter le
maximum possible de ses électeurs qui
hier était quand même des électeurs à
ses traditionnels et qui votait de le
plus souvent pour le grand parti de
droite quel que soit son nom d'ailleurs
dans l'histoire et qui aujourd'hui voit
un champ des possibles beaucoup plus
large qui s'interroge ce qui n'était pas
habituelle par le passé et qui peuvent
voter autant pour emmanuel macron pour
le candidat qui sortira du congrès est
pour une part d'entre eux et
éventuellement pour un eric zemmour
encore une part des recettes type sacha
oliech doit avaliser ce qui n' ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que en
sortant un petit peu du rôle d'acteur et
en regardant de sa d'un point de vue de
commentateurs le sentiment qu'on a c'est
que la période qu'on vit aujourd'hui
elle ressemble à celle du début de la
troisième république dans lequel vous
avez trois blocs qui sont identifiables
une droite qui s'est radicalisée et qui
est de mieux un corps est actionnaire et
conservateurs un peu comme l'était les
monarchies de l'époque une gauche qui
s'est elle même radicalisé avec un train
volet anti institutionnelle donc qu'on
entende soit dans la bouche d'un tribun
comme jean luc mélenchon ou de d'élus
locaux qui sont revendiquées dans une
posture qui n'est pas celle de ftn
szeged et puis exactement gadoue blanc
ou blanc qui et puis vous avez langue
lisse et la deuxième au milieu vous avez
forcément des gens qui de la social
démocratie et la droite libérale
défendre des idées d' interventionnisme
économique jusqu'à une idée d'un ordre
républicain et qui ils sont ou contre
l'inde ou ont décidé de s'organiser pour
qu'aucun des deux extrêmes ne
parviennent au pouvoir du débat qu au
fond si vous faites un peu dépouillés en
ce moment est-ce que c'est pas parce que
vous n'avez pas fait grand chose depuis
quatre ans quand on regarde les idées de
la droite aujourd'hui autour de
l'autorité retournent à leur travail et
retour des territoires
ça casse pas trois pattes à un canard
agrémentant sa droite depuis dix ans
c'est sympa ce que vous venez de la non
moi je
non oui en fait votre vraie question
c'est est la droite doit-elle avoir peur
d'eux
emmanuel macron non non et je ne vais
pas évité la problématique du grand
remplacement assuré vous mais non
pourquoi il ne doit pas avoir peur d'eux
des manières macron parce que
malheureusement sur deux thématiques
très cher aux français et pas seulement
à la droite il a totalement échoué vous
avez parlé du régalien doute à leur
écoute et la foudre jupitérienne avait
pas tomber sur les délinquants ou en
tous les cas les français s'en sont pas
rendu compte il ya un problème de
crédibilité en matière de sécurité et de
justice total du côté des manuels macron
et ça il ya un vrai désir besoin dans
les territoires de justice et de
sécurité deuxième point le pouvoir
d'achat ben c'est comme le pouvoir si
qu'olivier paco la sécurité à willem ii
kampala mais écoutez c'est celle
ci mais c'est surtout ses surnoms montée
panon c'est surtout la priorité de
beaucoup de français c'est la mission
première d'un état de protéger sa
population
deuxième chose excusez moi quand même le
pouvoir d'achat alors on va me dire le
pouvoir d'achat augmenter dites le aux
français quand ils vont faire leur plein
d'essence à quand ils remplissent leurs
caddies le pouvoir d'achat il n'a pas
augmenté et les mesures comme par
exemple l'indemnité inflation qui a été
financée qui va être financé en partie
par les rentrées fiscales hausse du prix
du gasoil et de l'essence a rapporté
énormément et dont on rend un tout petit
peu de ce qu'on a touché les français ne
sont pas dupes enfin je me permette de
répondre à votre question sur le grand
remplacement de ce que je fais pas du
tout gêné le dessus entre eric zemmour
par exemple et la libération il y aura
toujours une chose c'est la croix de
lorraine entre le gaullisme est celui
qui défend pétain et son gouvernement
il n'y a pas de pont aussi pourquoi
xavier bertrand réfute pas alors cette
thématique il la réussit pas il ne
répond pas ça il ne la réfute pas parce
que beaucoup avaient même chose rappelle
que la grande grand-place piment
développé par l'écrivain renaud camus
qui vise à dire que il ya remplacé il ya
un problème d'intégration par par les
immigrés mais moi je vous réponds et je
l'assumé totalement dans certains
quartiers il ya un problème
d'intégration si vous le nier c'est que
vous n'y est jamais allé non mais ils
ont fait ce terme ça donne quand même
une couleur au débat oui je ne veux non
je ne l'utiliserai pas
ne peut pas évacuer le problème de
l'immigration on ne résiste pas d'emploi
pas de remplacement enfin tant que ça il
ya ya ya ya entre eux entre les deux
termes il ya une réalité bien sûr une
réalité de l'intégration et
l'immigration si je vous comprends c'est
que le bilan des manèges macron selon
vous sur les thématiques de sécurité
soit éric de pouvoir d'inciter un boulet
pour l'immigration feront que il est
tellement mauvais que ça sera favorable
à la droite oui si je simplifie bien sûr
c'est ce que voulait dire mais c'est ça
on peut regarder s'il ya des
conséquences pour la gauche est ce que
le fait que le président de la
république se droitise entre guillemets
ou un espace politique à la gauche
notamment pour les écologistes par les
nations unies il n
ya qu à paris il ya quelques jours la
fondation jean jaurès
qui montre que lee un vote utile à
gauche et finalement le pas mal
d'électeurs de gauche on retrouve encore
dans les manuels bacon la jeune hôtesse
54% des sympathisants ps voteraient
pourraient voter pour emmanuel patron
mâcon premier tour 38% des sympathisants
écologistes votre et au premier tour le
menu accroc et même 25 % des défis donc
la france a soumis ce qu'on veut mais
des toits rassurer déclaration il a je
voulais dire donc là effectivement
depuis la déclaration d'hier avec et les
les allocations aux chômeurs qui
seraient revus pour le ce se qui ne sont
pas assez actif et et la refonte du
nucléaire je pense que ça peut évoluer
là dessus je juste avant de passer la
parole saoudien pierre-adrien bartoli ça
peut ouvrir un espace à la gauche que ce
soit la gauche écologiste ou à gauche
socialiste ça peut ouvrir un espace
après aujourd'hui on épand les électeurs
de gauche sont relativement perdu ils
ont une offre qui est importante aucune
qui correspond réellement à
aux attentes c'est vrai et on l'oublié
un peu il ya eu lieu en termes de
politique mené une forme de pivot en
tout cas de déplacement du centre de
gravité de la majorité plutôt sur la
droite néanmoins aujourd'hui
effectivement 56 % des gens qui se
sentent proches du ps qu'on appelle des
sympathisants font confiance emmanuel
macron dans la politique qui mène donc
emmanuel macron dans sa politique et
dans son positionnement ne s'est pas
coupé totalement des électeurs et des
français de gauche qui ont pu le porter
au pouvoir en 2017 après est ce que ces
prises de paroles là à elles seules
ouvre un espace sur la gauche difficile
à dire effectivement peut-être qu'il
faut suivre la question du nucléaire qui
est quand même une question qui divise
très nettement les français de gauche et
de droite avec grosso modo d'evans et de
droite qui sont attachés au principe du
nucléaire et qui sont même d'ailleurs
pour près d'un tiers d'entre favorable à
ce qu'on augmente sa part dans le mix
énergétique et des français de gauche
qui pour assez peu souhaite sortir
totalement du nucléaire mais néanmoins
souhaiteraient avoir un équilibre
probablement autour de 50% d'énergie
nucléaire d'une part d'énergies
renouvelables d'autre part merci adrien
à toi ça je voudrais vous donner
plusieurs observations d'abord par
rapport à ce qu'on me auger justesse
qu'il faut lui envoyer un signal à sec à
cet électorat de gauche vous savez
justement c'est ce que je voulais vous
dire parce qu'il ya des mesures qui
peuvent paraître de droite et qui ont
résonné dans le coeur de beaucoup de
gens qui sont des employés ou outils
sont des électeurs traditionnellement de
gauche et qui a 15 mai c'est la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui était une mesure qui
avait été créée par la droite qui a été
supprimée par la gauche et que de
nombreux députés ou électeurs de gauche
disent ça a été supprimée c'est une
bêtise nous avons rétabli et ça c'est
une mesure et c'est françois marc
françois hollande est donc ça par
exemple c'est une mesure et qui emporte
l'adhésion à gauche et qui pour autant
est identifié comme de droite parce que
il y avait une confiscation de la valeur
travail par la droite n'est qu'il est
injustifié maintenant sur le deuxième
thème que vous avez porté qui est celui
du nucléaire le nucléaire il faut pas le
prendre isolément nucléaire c'est un mix
énergétique est ce que l'on dit sur le
nucléaire c'est d'abord que l'on va
sortir de toutes les générations
fossiles c'est la première chose qu'on
suit on va réduire la consommation
d'énergie en france parce qu'on va
passer 2006 térawattheures à 645 5
térawattheures et qu'on va produire tout
cela en énergies décarbonées et que pour
cela comme on ne sait pas faire ou comme
on ne choisit de ne pas faire 100%
d'énergies renouvelables pour ne pas
avoir une occupation de tout le
territoire eh bien on faire un mix
énergétique vous allez avoir une plaie à
la faire passer de gauche toute une
partie de la gauche qui sait je vous ai
dit alors qu'était productiviste du
nucléaire est incertain et le sioniste
jeudi martin je suis allé voir ben et
ensuite ce que je vous dis c'est que
effectivement il ya toute une partie de
la gauche et notamment la gauche
communiste qui était très favorable au
nucléaire et qu'il est demeuré au nom de
l'emploi a notamment déjà lundi soir
xavier bertrand à la france assure voilà
non la gauche 18 disparus il représente
le grand chose c'est le concert juste
lundi soir xavier bertrand dit ma
première mesure si je suis élu essaie de
construire des centrales nucléaires
mardi soir oui emmanuel macron observer
qu on avait annoncé la construction de
ce
moment enfin moi je me permets de
rajouter une petite chose qui qui
effectivement malheureusement en rangs
très floues ou l'attitude du président
de la république c'est le roi du zig zag
ou de la volte face personne ne peut
nier qu'on à fermer fessenheim alors
qu'elle pouvait continuer à fonctionner
je vais dire ce que vous voulez mais
vous dirai ça aux gens de fessenheim
bon et aujourd'hui on fait l'inversé moi
je me fais moi qui sévit dans la région
je me félicite que le président la
république veut relancer le nucléaire je
vous le dis très franchement parce que
c'est une mesure
d'indépendance de souveraineté
énergétique essentiel créatrice
d'emplois et c'est une énergie propre
alors qu'il faille effectivement aussi
mettre un effort sur les autres énergies
renouvelables pas l'éolien parce que
l'éolien quand il ya justement 6 il faut
en parler quand on nous parle de
l'éolien et qu'à côté on nous dit que
l'artificialisation des sols est une
catastrophe eh ben je crois qu'on n'est
pas cohérent parce que l'ema qui sont
plantés sur les énormes de tomber ton
l'eau en raison pour laquelle le
scénario n 02 rte ont traîné
donnez-moi très technique un petit peu
notre débat oui à la méthanisation
oui aux halles ou photovoltaïque mais
l'éolien les audiences ont également
suffi à en parler dans notre rubrique
les électorats parole albert et nous est
ce que ces zigzags comme des zones de
bas coûts cette droitisation ou ceux et
en même temps est-ce que ça peut gêner
la construction de cette fameuse maison
commune de la majorité à votre avis la
maison commune de la majorité elle et
elle est quand même elle pense quand
même plutôt centre droit donc il y à
quelques quelques éléments quelques
éléments de gauche qui est qui se
rattache territoire de progrès mais on
voit bien que clairement la volonté est
d'aller plutôt vers le centre c'est donc
à une lutte interne fratricide entre
entre françois bayrou par exemple et
edouard philippe il doit philippe
on ne sait pas droit bien qu'il ya une
volonté d un peu plus de droite qui
emmanuel macron mais je suis pas dans
l'esprit d'edouard philippe ni dans sa
barbe et vous seriez avec un décor
philippe dans la majorité il a été chef
de la majorité pour en deux ans en
faisant même donc à vous dire qu'on est
mal à l'aise avec lui mais les choses
devraient peut-être plus clair ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des désaccords on
a eu des discussion assez vive avec
edouard philippe c'est connu sur l'après
une activité soit au cg sur la question
de l'âge légal de départ déjà à l'époque
et donc qu'il y ait des débats dans la
majorité sur ces questions là c'est
depuis cinq ans que ça existe et ça va
probablement par une aile plus de
désaccords sur l'âge légal de départ
non mais moi j'ai toujours dit que la
ligne
l'âge légal pour le coup il doit être
d'abord interrogés par rapport aux
carrières longues est-ce qu'on permet
toujours aux gens qui ont fait des
carrières longues de barques dire tout
et il doit être aussi interrogé par
rapport au fait qu' on est des gens qui
sont des seniors qui sont aujourd'hui
n'ont pas d'emploi à partir de 55 57 ans
et c'est si on va faire travailler plus
les gens c'est aussi ces personnes là
qui doivent pouvoir travailler jusqu'au
bout et ça c'est des conditions qui
doivent nous permettre ensuite de
reporter l'âge légal donc vous n'avez
pas vu de virage hier ces discussions
font ou le maquereau nice met une
idéologie
mathis est à nos portes et je pense
qu'on n'aura pas hélas réussi à conclure
ce soir sur ce thème mais en tout cas
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat olivier paccaud ce chat ollier
albert et nous pierre-adrien bartoli
laetitia vous rester avec moi pour la
suite de l'émission